do you trust men less because of what  you've learned from doing this of course  I don't trust no [ __ ] I don't give a  [ __ ] what that [ __ ] tell me I don't  trust that that [ __ ] could tell me  [ __ ] I love you I don't you don't love  me that much [ __ ] cause a [ __ ] that  loved you that [ __ ] gonna tell you  [ __ ] you don't need to be out here  [ __ ]  I'm gonna go buy it that's a real [ __ ]  you know what I'm saying that's a man  right there you feel me that's not no he  could be a pimp you know I don't say I  want to square but he could be a pimp  you know what I'm saying saying [ __ ]  you don't got to be here a lot of pimps  don't want these [ __ ] on here you  feel me a pimp could have a [ __ ] on  Mega perk you know what I'm saying on on  whole sites instead of outside you feel  me because they know this [ __ ] is  dangerous  you hear what I'm saying yeah it's a  very dangerous lifestyle so I'm telling  Gary  well you're working the track still yes  you're not